sous cette colline d'apparence anodine
du village de keur panneaux thériault se
trouve ce qui aurait été le plus haut
lieu de pouvoir au pays
advenant une guerre nucléaire autrefois
secret il est aujourd'hui possible de
visiter le plus grand bunker au monde
dédié à l'interprétation de la guerre
froide carpet une petite ville à
l'extérieur d'ottawa puis derrière moi
vous voyez ce qu'on appelle le différend
que le défunt banker doit son nom au
premier ministre john diefenbaker qui a
ordonné la construction de cet abri
antinucléaire en 1959 par crainte d'une
attaque par bombes atomiques sur la
capitale du canada
si jamais il y avait eu à ce moment là
une crise nucléaire on avait quand même
deux sièges de gouvernement ici faut
prendre les décisions importantes pour
les canadiens en cas d' alerte de 500 à
600 personnes essentielles au
fonctionnement du gouvernement aurait dû
emprunter ce tunnel de 150 m pour
accéder aux bunkers souterrains puis il
vivre en confinement pour une durée de
30 jours à l'intérieur des dortoirs une
cafétéria un hôpital miniature avec
salles d'opération même un studio de
radio canada prêt à diffuser les
messages d'urgence
ici on a le bureau du secrétaire des
premiers ministres jusque là on a le
bureau du premier ministre lui même sa
propre chambre à coucher et sa propre
étoile est on a même prévu une voûte
pour entreposer les lingots d'or du
canada en toute sécurité utilisés
jusqu'en 1994 comme base de
télécommunications des forces armées
canadiennes le bunker était toujours
prêt à l'accueillir le gouverneur
général le premier ministre et les
membres de son cabinet on était toujours
prêt de pour amener tous les ministres
fédéral le gouvernement
les militaires ici pour un confinement
de 30 jours les gens qui vont visiter le
faire les parallèles non seulement avec
la crise la pandémie coville mais aussi
avec d'autres explosions qui arrivait
tous ceux qui commencent à la fiq le
quotidien des gens le musée des fins de
banker dont les visées de sont désormais
possibles virtuellement témoigne de
cette époque où on se préparer au pire
et un autre type de confinement qui
aurait changé le cours de l'histoire ici
boris proulx
radio canada ottawa